to go back to nietzsche
is there some aspect to where if we try
to explain the forces of play here
is it the will to power playing itself
out
from individual human nature and from
group behavior nature
uh is there some elements to this which
is the game we play as human beings
is always when we have less power we try
to find ways to gain more power that's
certainly one um the desire to to grab
is let me see if i find a quote for you
on that
the desire to grab
that which we think we're owed
and to do it
often in the guise of um
justice
i mean
justice is one of the great terms of our
age and one of the very great bogus
terms of our age
people forever talk about their search
for justice it's amazing how violent
they can often be in their search for
justice and how many rules they're
willing to break so long as they can say
they're after justice and how many norms
they can trample so long as they can say
it's in the name of justice you can burn
down buildings in the name of justice
well the the majority groups throughout
history including those with white skin
color have done the same in the name of
justice we came up with all kinds of
sexy terms in our propaganda machines to
sell whatever atrocities we'd like to
commit
one of the one of the quotes of uh from
nietzsche that i liked and i quoted in
this careful i'm judging you harshly
yeah of course
nietzsche says that one of the dangers
of men of resentment is they'll achieve
their ultimate form of revenge which is
to turn happy people into unhappy people
like themselves to shove their misery in
the faces of the happy so that in due
course the happy and this is quoting
nature start to be ashamed of their
happiness and perhaps say to one another
it's a disgrace to be happy there is too
much misery
this is something to be averted for the
sick says nietzsche must not make the
healthy sick to or make the healthy
confuse themselves with the sick
well
i think there again there's a lot of
that going on how could i be happy when
there is unhappiness in the world why
should i not join the ranks of the
unhappy
you